and
let's start off our edition of which
doesn't belong and why by staying in
tampa and looking at that quarterback
depth chart three names on it tom brady
blaine gabbert kyle trask which doesn't
belong and why
well i'm going to go with blaine gabbert
because he's the only one on the list
who was a first round draft pick right
so that's who i'm gonna go with and he
was 13
13 and 35 in his career as a starter
mike 50 touchdowns 47 interceptions i
don't know what bruce aryan sees in
blaine gabert but he hasn't shown the
rest of us
anything to to think that he's the most
underrated player in this league
if blaine gabbard becomes the starter at
some point and has a really good year
would you vote for him for comeback
player of the year
uh
yeah probably not
[Music]
all right i'll oh well i mean the easy
one's brady i mean brady's brady no one
else is brady brady stands out head and
shoulders above all quarterbacks
and and the question is how much of
his way
his approach his work ethic his
leadership can rub off on these other
guys maybe blaine gabridges needed to
spend a couple of years in the master
class that tom brady puts on on a
consistent basis maybe he just needed to
learn how to be an nfl quarterback you
know these guys get sucked into the nfl
they get thrust into a starting job they
don't necessarily have anyone to show
them what to do that is such an
underrated aspect of someone's
individual nfl journey jameis winston
after one year with drew brees he could
be a completely different quarterback
this year we don't know he was so
emotional when he was talking about
brees after brees retired we don't know
how that incorporates itself into the
way that a quarterback operates so brady
is brady he's clearly separate from the
rest i'm curious to see how much of
brady trickles down to gabbard and trask
and does set the stage for success in
the future all right nfc head coaches
with one super bowl title which doesn't
belong in y bruce aryans
pete carroll
sean payton obviously mike mccarthy has
a super bowl title but not with the team
that he's currently coaching for who
doesn't belong and why from ariens carol
and peyton
i'm gonna go with arians because he's
won the one championship he should have
won as a head coach when you look at
sean payton and having drew brees all
the year those years and i have the
record in front of me i mean 12 wins 13
wins 13 wins 11 wins
the last four years couldn't get it done
couldn't get that second championship
with drew brees which i just find
unfathomable and and we all know that
that they got cheated out of that one
against the rams they would have been
back in the super bowl they would have
had a great chance to win that game if
they had gotten back there but they
didn't it was a bad call against them
and and things have gone against them
you look at the you know the minnesota
game when they lost that one at the end
they've just had so many bad things uh
go against them but they should have had
more than one championship frankly and
pete carroll i mean if not for the
malcolm butler play he's got two
championships and should have two
championships so to me bruce arians is
the only one with that one championship
who has won the one time that he should
have won it these other guys to me they
should have more championships mike than
what they have
well the bounty scandal screwed the
saints up for 2012 and for multiple
years beyond that as they kind of
rebuilt the defense after the last
season the offense continued to be very
good and then that 17 18 19
excuse me 20. i tried to hold that cough
off as best i could i apologize but
those last four years to have those
heartbreaking
exits from the postseason um
so i see where you're coming from arians
had one team
that was good enough to win it and he
took that team anyone although he had
some good teams in arizona got to an nfc
championship i'll say pete carroll
doesn't belong because
taking your point
and really honing it down
carol's got no excuses
for
not having the team around russell
wilson
and and and
here's the other side of it carol's the
one of the three coaches who currently
is in one of these messes
with his quarterback you know tom brady
wants to be in tampa
taysom hill and jameis winston want to
be in new orleans
we don't know what russell wilson wants
we don't know how long he's going to be
there and there has been i think a sense
that the seahawks haven't
really lived up to the excellence that
we saw
2012-13-14
especially 13-14 and we're getting
farther and farther away from the last
time the seahawks have made it to super
i don't think they've been back to an
nfc championship since their last super
bowl appearance
which uh it's getting deeper and deeper
into the rear view mirror all right afc
head coaches with one super bowl title
andy reed of the chiefs john harbaugh of
the ravens mike tomlin of the steelers
which doesn't belong and why
well i'm going to go with andy reed on
this one because i think he's a hall of
fame coach and everybody was so excited
when he finally won that that first
championship right but you know if he
retired five years from now now that we
have the coaching category i think he's
in the hall of fame and i think he's the
one guy on that list even if you didn't
have the coaching category which just
came in a couple years ago i think he
would still be a first ballot hall of
famer if not first ballot maybe second
like bill parcells i think went in his
second time around after he unretired
came back whatever but i do think that
andy reid would be a pretty automatic
choice to go into the hall of fame
whether the coaching category was there
or not just what he's done the wins he
has i mean he just keeps compiling them
and i think this is a coach that's going
to win more than one super bowl those
other guys have won their super bowls
they've had some great teams around them
they're not andy reid they haven't quite
done what he's done yet mike
he's been a head coach in the nfl every
year since 1999 and i remember when the
eagles not just made andy reid the head
coach but basically gave him the keys to
the franchise put him in charge of the
football operation my reaction was who
the hell is andy reid that was before i
was in the business but that was the
widespread reaction nobody knew who andy
reid was for the most part we found out
fairly quickly he's had great teams
pretty much every year since 1999. i'll
say john harbaugh just because he's the
guy who was the special teams
coordinator he had one year as a
position coach defensive backs coach
just as like a pallet cleanser because
nobody hires special teams coordinators
to be head coaches it's amazing to me
that that still is the case we hear the
arguments from time to time special
teams coordinator used to dealing with
guys on both sides of the ball the
closest thing of any of the three
coordinators to a head coach because you
do have to pull a team together you
don't have your little niche here
offense steve no you you have to know
everyone you have to work with everyone
you have to motivate everyone
and harbaugh despite having
some
offensive coordinators who
weren't among the best football minds
available still contending teams
relevant teams
super bowl win and and in the
conversation on a regular basis so i i
think for that reason harbaugh stands
out shereen because of that special
teams background aren't you amazed that
that really hasn't caught on dave tobe
the
the special teams coordinator in kansas
city he he kind of was on the fringes of
consideration at one point but but none
of these special teams guys can punch
through
it is amazing and and so many of them
want to become head coaches and they
just haven't gotten that opportunity
mike and i thought that harbaugh would
open the door for these guys to get more
of those opportunities and it just
hasn't happened
all right one more topic real quickly
which doesn't belong and why
quarterbacks entering their fourth years
and in line for contract extensions josh
allen lamar jackson baker mayfield which
doesn't belong and why
well i i'm gonna go with lamar jackson
because he's the guy with the mvp award
right and and he's the guy that i think
the the ravens are sold on despite being
ranked last in in passing yards in the
nfl last season so i think he's going to
get his extension i think josh allen's
going to get his extension i think baker
mayfield gets his but i do still have a
little bit of a question about baker
mayfield just
is he going to do what he did at the end
of the season is he going to continue to
take that next step the brown sound
convinced that he's going to do that i'm
going to be surprised if they don't wait
to make sure that that's the case though
mike
you know andrew berry the gm of the team
recently with the ross tucker football
podcast talking about these issues of
when do you sign the quarterback and is
it a cautionary tale what happened with
carson wentz and jared goff sims and i
talked about this yesterday yes it is a
cautionary tale you better be damn sure
when you make that move if you're sure
about the guy you get him signed after
three years if you're not sure you'll
wait to me mayfield stands out because
the ravens should be sure about jackson
the bills should be sure about allen
i don't because of 2019 and because it
took him a while in 2020 to really reach
that high level i'd want to give it one
more year and i know it's going to cost
me
if i wait but i want to give it that one
more year and see
if he can play
all year long like we saw him at the end
of the season and if so he's a guy you
never let go but at the end of the day
it's all based on merit except for the
90th spot on the jaguars roster and
merit is what's going to deliver a
contract for baker mayfield because you
don't want to get yourself in a position
where you've forked over the huge money
and you get a few years into it and you
ask yourself what the hell
are we doing here's what we're doing
we're taking a break when we return the
draft as promised julio jones had the
great catch in super bowl 51 that felt
like the dagger and wasn't the all-time
great plays
produced by
the team that ultimately
lost the game we'll draft that next here
on pft live
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports